so you'd rather do Alaska in the cold
than Mississippi in the summer yes yeah
cuz I don't like to sweat cuz then you
know my face will start melting
you know I paint all my eyebrows in the
cold they stay perfect yeah it's really
good paint on your eyebrows yes this
isn't real no nothing you got a hair
none everything is just not right I'm
not even a person yeah he's just a small
Mexican man what's up everybody I'm
Krista Stefano welcome to stupid
questions with me
Sydney Washington you know her from
Comedy Central's up next showcase at
cluster fest and also her podcast the
unofficial expert whoo what's the
weirdest phobia you've ever had I'm
scared of dying on a plane really yes
because then it's not a tragedy about me
it's a tragedy with me and like 150
other people so it's not as special nice
so you want to die in a special way
where that could have only happened to
you yes just me I like jessamy what's it
what's a good way to go out give us your
perfect death okay I was on a horse
right and I'm riding the horse on my
state and then the horse all of a sudden
goes crazy and attacks me and I fall off
the horse and then I died
beautiful white one here what's my
pearls yeah yeah can I just get stepped
on by a horse like a white one Carrodus
makes sense to me folks what's the
weirdest thing anyone ever ordered or
did to you while you were waitress a
woman pulled out her own buns for
burgers okay these are my book not back
how was work anyway she's like I made
these buns we're going to only eat the
buns that I make so I would like a
burger a medium well
but with these buns watch she pulled out
her buns and I said miss you gots to go
we don't want your buns or your son
gonna take the budget uh listen boy your
ex in the buns that's a good point
what if there's anthrax in the bun so
buns look dry I was like no thank you I
know there's no butter or anything this
restaurant not a dry ass anthrax
Washington's restaurant once the best
theme party you've ever been to 90s
yeah party yeah because a lot of people
don't update their clothes anyway so I'm
all they had to do is go in the closet
they didn't even have to go shop or
nothing well I feel like it's coming
back now everybody's wearing a 90s
vintage thing now or windbreakers
something about a windbreaker I love a
good windbreaker though I love it shot
like that on the pants I love to feel
like like I'm like coming I want people
to hear me come woo that doesn't sound
good say it again I want people to hear
me come because none of those people
hear women coming anyway so like
honestly I know I haven't all right
Sydney that was stupid questions you
have a good time laughs seriously so
fine you know what you get a stupid gift
now so cuz you're Lansing's Washington
we framed a dollar bill because that's
George Washington and we gave it to you
yeah that's for you babe there's another
gift I got you cuz your first name
Sydney and dad sounds like a tent city
in Australia I got you a koala bear
[Laughter]
[Music]